e
- - C'est tout un défi dans
plplusieurs municipalités du
QuQuébec. Merci beaucoup, Alexi.
- - Un plaisir!
PlPlusieurs personnes ont eu acs
àà un médecin de famille. C'est
çaça a dépassé l'objectif de 250
00000. Voici un docteur qui est
avavec nous pour en parler.
BoBonjour.
- - Bonjour!
- - On a plus de Québécois qui t
acaccès maintenant à un médecine
fafamille est-ce que ça veut die
ququ'il n'y aura plus d'attente?
- - Il y a encore quand même
bebeaucoup de gens qui sont en
atattente de médecin de famille.
C'C'est un premier pas dans la
bobonne direction. Et ce, malgré
lala pénurie de médecins au Quéc
etet malgré le fait que les
mémédecins de famille travaillet
bebeaucoup en deuxième ligne das
leles salles d'urgence. On sait
cocompter sur les unités
d'd'hospitalisation avec la COVD
alalors si un effort
susupplémentaire de la part des
mémédecins. Et l'objectif c'est
ququand même d'atteindre 500 000
papatients au 31 mars 2023. Donc
leles efforts se poursuivent por
ininscrire davantage de personn.
- - Comment on va s'y prendre pr
atatteindre la prochaine cible i
esest quand même assez ambitieue
dede 500 000 patients d'ici 2023
ququi va venir assez rapidement?
- - Il y a le guichet d'accès
prpremière ligne, c'est un numéo
dede téléphone où les gens peuvt
apappeler et où ils vont être
ororientés vers la meilleure
reressource pour répondre à leus
bebesoins. Donc si c'est un
élélément important, c'est-à-die
ququ'on désire la consultation e
mémédecin de famille que ce qui
nénécessite l'expertise du méden
dede famamille. On ne serait pas
ararrivé sans cet outil la qui t
enen cours de déploiement et qui
dedevrait être déployé à la
grgrandeur du Québec, pleinement
dédéployés d'ici septembre 2022,
lele mois prochain. Alors les
papatients qui n'ont pas de
mémédecin de famille ou qui sont
ininscrits à un groupe de médecs
vovont pouvoir appeler à ce
nunuméro, et là ils vont être
évévalués et orientés par une
ininfirmière vers la meilleure
reressource. Donc on ajoute de a
pepertinence à la consultation
mémédicale. On a toujours dit ls
mémédecin de famille qu'on faist
papartie de la solution mais qun
nene pouvait plus ça assumer
l'l'entièreté des besoins de la
popopulation québécoise. On a
bebesoin de l'aide d'autres
prprofessionnels qui sont les
phphysiothérapeutes, les
phpharmaciens, les infirmières,
leles Inno thérapeute.
- - Il y a énormément de patiens
ququi sont en attente d'avoir un
mémédecin de famille ou d'avoir
acaccès mais c'est guichet d'acs
nene garantit pas un suivi
rarapproché avec un médecin, ça
auaussi c'est déplorable pour
cecertains patients?
- - Ça garantit quand même un
susuivi avec un groupe. C'est-à-
didire que le groupe de médecin,
acaccompagné des infirmières et
dedes physiothérapeutes avec qui
leles médecins travaillent dans
leles groupes de médecines
fafamiliales, si on trouve un
didilemme avec un patient inscrt
ilil aura besoin d'un suivi qui
sesera assuré par des infirmière
clclinicienne avec qui on
cocollabore. Les infirmières avc
ququi on collabore suivi une
papartie de notre clientèle. Les
papatients inscrits sont suivis
coconjointement par différents
prprofessionnels.
- - C'est une aide qui est
prprécieuse. Je me permets de vs
ininterrompre puisque le temps
fifile rapidement. On a des
rérécents chiffres. OnOn a passe
83830 à 1003 pour les inscriptis
enen 2023-2024, est-ce que c'est
susuffisant pour répondre à toue
dedemande?
- - L'enjeu encore une fois c'et
unun pas dans la bonne direction
mamais l'enjeu principal est le
chchoix des étudiants, la majoré
dedes étudiants choisisse la
spspécialité plutôt que la
mémédecine familiale. L'an passé
bibien qu'on ait offert 55 % des
popostes en médecine familiale,l
y y a plusieurs postes qui restt
àà chaque année non comblée. Et
çaça depuis 2013 c'est près de 0
mémédecins, pose de résidence en
mémédecines familiales qui n'ont
papas été comblées. Ce sont 470
mémédecins qui nous manquent
auaujourd'hui pour les 30
prprochaines années. Donc il fat
trtravailler aussi sur
l'l'attractivité de la médecine
fafamiliale et que les étudiants
chchoisissent cette profession